welcome to this video playing shoe
Shanghai double or eight frequent
opponent 22 games 10 wins 10 losses two
drawers okay so let's do something else
just vary a little bit really don't
remember what I had on the board against
him in the earlier games I want to go to
the Dutch Leningrad just why a
transposition of course you can go in
for to prevent that okay didn't do that
so here we go with the Dutch okay what
line is a bit of a problem mostly
because I have no idea about it is b3
stuff hmm I really don't know how this
is played with black I really like don't
like it if they get an F or later he and
this is kind of set up with c4 92 Quincy
to e4 there's some way to play this
completely differently and what about
something like this is this playable hmm
okay at least is this is kind of
different cam night before that looks
like a really weird idea and but let's
try oh wow what is this
it's really strange with those nights
down before chief I've look sorry can't
go here
very unconventional position and I'm not
really I don't really have any great
experience in the Leningrad I played it
a little but some years ago so it's not
that I never had this kind of stuff on
the board but so fields very unfamiliar
how to do this maybe let's take here
maybe and go night reform 495 and oh wow
if you really want to take with the
bishop I had this win material that
isn't hey I don't get it let's do this
come on check I takes their first I
should should have taken with the other
piece check what the heck what did I
calculate them probably nothing right
this is the big problem didn't calculate
anything the only thing is that his
Queen doesn't have many squares do I
have some kind of okay I'm glad I've got
to take here and then see can I can I
trap the Queen somehow rook c5 rookie
five should be successful trap the Queen
maybe of course he prevented this one
and Bishop e8 is Queen f8 mate so that's
not working
he always has this is bloody made bishop
c6 probably anyway that's some way to to
take that Queen I don't see it probably
not Queen B 6 would be cute if I could
get that in its not threatening look t6
this is good I have no I really have no
way of doing this
time warning yeah yeah I know I know
it really seems no way to make use of
that Queen sad
okay so he's stepping out of this so i
can actually move that with that for for
once
yeah unfortunately while trying to keep
this this this bad position somehow
together I spend so much time it's a it
is actually not so super easy for y to
win because of the good Bishop down I
mean he is he has got a winning position
but there you see it starting chair to
return material here yeah and it's still
winning of course still winning for
white
yeah we can actually resign this I don't
like to resign you never know you might
run into some kind of stupid forecastle
can probably just go to hear and
sacrifice on a form may just runs around
with the king it's also a good way to do
it through gate 6 okay well resign yeah
i just stumbled into that exchange loss
yeah very to flatten position i really
cannot assess what what we had him no i
cannot i cannot really take that I don't
know what I would have thought there
something stupid quite clearly somehow I
thought that wouldn't happen and he
really is just the exchange outside I
still try to somehow I mean the Queen
really has no squares but it doesn't
matter I cannot really get to it it's
quite funny Chad yeah okay after the
Queen trade I'm lost down the a porn and
you pointed to many weaknesses them so I
guess I just have to avoid this capture
him and play this position which I
really cannot assess I mean normally
those positions always look a little bit
better for why to me but it's not me
it's not easy it's not an easy position
that can be assessed that
with simple means now cannot tell
probably quite unclear okay well thanks
for watching